so I hope this is not true so there's a
rumored run time for mandolin season 3
finale and it is 38 minutes long and I
believe this also includes the end
credits and a little recap at the start
so it means this episode could only be
like 34 minutes long which I think for
finale is very very lackluster
especially considering we haven't got
much story development this season and
there are so many things to wrap up so I
feel like it will be very hard to do in
this short amount of time but who knows
I could be wrong as I've said in the
past runtime does not correlate to the
quality of a project if this is true I
hope this episode just begins and gets
straight into it there's no Thriller No
wasting time because there's heaps of
things to wrap up we have the mythosol
we have din jarobin captured we have
demand Lawrence above mandal that about
to be attacked and all these other story
points which haven't been really covered
too much like the Clone in and with moth
get in so there's so much things I was
hoping this episode was going to be
close to an hour long but that seems
like it may not be the case but what do
you guys think let me know in the
comment section below do think this is
enough run time share your thoughts
below and also if you're new to Channel
please consider subscribing thanks for
watching